let me start by saying the movies
fantastic and all the performances just
it's just very well done the thing I
think that sometimes a movie is made and
you never know what is going to come out
in the world but it seems like this is
like the perfect time from you know this
story especially with just what's going
on with the world the last few days yeah
you know could you sort of talk about
like the story of the film and just kind
of the timing of it if you don't mind I
think that this form of journalism and
people who risk literally everything to
tell us the truth of what's happening to
civilian lives in these war-torn places
is is something that is some essential
know when the way people receive news
and the fake news aspect of it all this
is you know it's like it's a movie it's
it's entertainment but it does have an
important message and I do think you're
right I think it feels very timely that
that we're shedding light on all of
these people go through to tell us the
truth when truthful news is so hard to
get these days yeah I mean it's like in
reality this should have been a bit of a
historical movie mmm you know because
when Mia Marie when I came out seven
years ago now and I wrote the book and
we you know whispers our films no one
thought it'd still be gone in seven
years time you know this in reality if
everything had gone well the world had
been over five six years ago this would
have been a flashback to the world but
actually it's still going on you know
and that you know time and wise you know
it couldn't be better for that for that
reason you know and it's at the stage in
the war where people are starting to
think it's over and you know the Assads
is slowly been weaned back onto the
international circuit so you know with
this coming out showing that you know
what these people did you know it sad
but the timing is is quite spot-on for
it would about see the final chapter in
Homs in Eid Lib and and this is coming
out so I couldn't be better people go
and see this and start still keep asking
questions and it's it's done it a world
of good one of the things that I found
really interesting was the fact that you
guys used non-professional actor
people that have really lived these
experiences being part of the film can
you sort of talk about working with
people who'd been there and how that
maybe changes the energy on set well
Jesus I mean the certainty did change
the energy one or two or three or four
or five I mean so many times that
spilled into something that was just
very sort of uncontrollable and
heightened in terms of emotion and
people lost it and you know in the
burial scene in Iraq we have women who
were really there and that was you know
bringing up memories of stuff that had
happened to them and it was harrowing
and you know it's a strange line between
documenting that yeah and filming these
people who are in real distress and you
know PTSD with these situations and you
know but also comforting them as well
and yes and yeah that interaction I
never thought it was gonna be like that
no there were times when it did get real
you know people come up and hug it out
one guy came up and pulled his t-shirt
don't eat full of bullet holes and I
said why don't you goes I was in Baba
Amro
when you guys were there but also I
think it's like sometimes they don't you
know some you know they've been
approached and it's a day's work and
they'll get paid quite well to be an
extra for a day or two whatever it is
and then maybe sometimes I'm prepared
for how real you can make those
situations look you know and they're
they're designed to a point that to
every detail and it just got all too
real for people but you know on a
selfish point of view that was kind of
amazing to feed off that energy a lot of
the time you know it's completely uh
talked a little bit about the first time
you guys met and maybe how you bonded
and you know was a probe involved right
and chicken wings yeah we'd been an
email contact a lot before that before
the the film started shooting and you
know um I'd read Paul's back onto the
wirelessly and seen every footage of
Paul that I could manage but we weren't
able to meet until we know we started
like sounds but her schedules way
crazier than my dad you know always away
so we actually didn't meet until we're
flying to a man to Jordan to start
shooting the movie and we then you know
find a pub when we landed and started
some really kinda sit there and go okay
here's a few notes on me no no it wasn't
gonna wear that would have just been
creepy when they like now try this
that's so now we just rent the poem
nerds like on you to do that yeah I mean
I don't know what I am Who I am
so how he was gonna find out I never
know what sir and I know I have to go
but was it like a mannerism or two that
you saw that you were looking at that at
that drinking hanging out and you're
like I got to remember this there's a
few things there's a few things but then
also like what what I had the you know
the foam moves a lot and sometimes
that's appropriate but the main thing
for me release is accents you know I I'm
very different parts of the world and we
saw him very different maybe not the
Americans I mean I see I there's a
screening in New York and this guy was
talking about the toilet and he was like
um he was that guy was great man it's
like a great thanks you work your ass
off to do these accents or so and he's
like that's great too he was Scottish
well yeah well thank you so much
congrats on the movie I really am happy
it was made every day thanks man
you